hi i'm michelle williams and i'm playing
the last time i
on the kelly clarkson show
[Music]
the last time i laughed so hard i
cried wow um
um um oh yesterday yesterday yesterday
with my best friend
yes she sent me a real that was on
instagram
and we were just cracking up
and then i ended up facetiming her and
we were just going crazy i'm all hanging
over
um the what do you call the bar thing in
the kitchen and we're just going
hilariously and then she was getting her
hair done
so the guy doing her hair is like come
on what are y'all doing
it was an inside joke too those are best
the last time i treated myself was
yesterday as well
i went to the mall i bought
two pair of shoes and
um they're now still sitting in the bag
because i'm wondering did i make the
right decision oprah always said if you
have to think twice about a purchase
don't buy it i didn't think twice about
it but
i think it's you know what it's when i
buy for others
it's quick but when it's for me i'm like
do i need this should i blah blah blah
so i'm gonna keep them the last time i
checked in with the destiny's child
ladies
was yesterday as well everything
happened yesterday
the shoes the best friend
and checking in with beyonce and kelly
all was yesterday
we are always checking in and to be
honest it's a blessing to
you know still have that connection
[Music]
last time i read a book i could not put
down
um has been the past few weeks some
friends of mines have
they have books out um they made the new
york times bestseller
sarah jakes roberts uh leslie jordan and
sonny hostin so
i'm thankful um to be able to have read
their books within the past month or two
last time i bought a plant
[Music]
i'm so proud of this this is a zanzibar
she's doing so good this is a snake
plant
and i don't know if it's growth is
stunted i'm gonna re-pop them
so just just stay tuned just stay tuned
but um the last time i bought plants
it's been about about two months someone
actually gave me a birkin
plant and as a gift it's really pretty
yeah that's my baby for right now those
are my kids
right now y'all i had so much fun
playing the last time
i um those were great questions by the
way you guys
um and please catch me this week oh my
girl the kelly clarkson show
uh thank y'all for your love and support
for my new book
checking in i just truly want to bring
healing through my story and to
make impact yep i'm still here just
waiting for you to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever